[Musique]
quand vous regardez chaque petit détail dans
le bracelet sombre,
ces choses sont le sommet de l'art de quelqu'un,
il y a quelques personnes qui savent comment
nous l'avons fait la première fois et nous sommes si
vieux que nous ne nous souvenons pas que tout est et
sculpté  et peint juste une
quantité incroyable de savoir-faire que vous voyez
sur toute l'image la première chose
que vous essayez de faire est d'être à la hauteur de ce que
le film a produit la prochaine étape est ensuite
de le pousser beaucoup plus loin, je pense que donner
Hanson aurait été
marionnettes ravies c'est une forme d'art en soi et
c'est ce que vous regardez
J'ai l'impression que Luke est vraiment la bonne
personne pour se tenir à la place de mon père
regardez le spectacle et vous oubliez de
regarder des marionnettes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements  ]
valetroy destin était un meilleur
[Musique]
toi